donde nos quedamos en el vídeo anterior
simplificamos un poco el polinomio p de
x de esta forma pero aún no parece tan
tratable así que aquí vamos a necesitar
nuevamente nuevamente de una idea genial
como para decir algo así como bajada ya
sé cómo resolverlo y es y es usarlo
justo en este en este polinomio azul que
que encontramos muy bien aquí es en
donde vamos a necesitar otra muy buena
idea y esencialmente lo que podemos ver
aquí es que tenemos la suma de las
potencias de x que eso es una serie
geométrica finita y que hemos visto en
otros vídeos como cómo podemos
simplificar esto bueno digamos que ese
es justamente esta suma que es un bueno
lo voy a poner como x así como esta x a
la 23 más x a la 22 más x a la 21 más
todos estos hasta x digamos más x1 ok y
ahora voy a escribir quién es x por s
quién es x por ese entonces si
multiplicamos por x
esta suma tendremos x a la 24 más x x x
a la 22 es x a la 23 más x x x a la 21
es x a la 22 y así podemos ir sumando x
a la 21 más todos sumamos todos estos
tendremos
de ser un poquito espacio más x cuadrada
que es x x x y x x 1 es x muy bien
entonces lo que yo quiero hacer ahora es
restar los porque los quiero restar pues
porque se parecen mucho verdad se
parecen mucho en varios términos
entonces si yo quiero calcular ese menos
x s
esto será igual bueno podemos ver que
estos se cancelan estos también estos
también todos se cancelan y sólo sólo
sobrevive este uno y menos x a la 24
entonces tenemos uno menos x a la 24 que
de hecho por ejemplo si multiplicamos
por menos uno de ambos lados tendremos x
s menos s igual a x a la 24 menos 1 muy
bien y finalmente si uno quiere por
ejemplo este y saber quién es ese pues
simplemente lo factor izamos de aquí
verdad tenemos ese hilo factor izamos
tenemos ese que multiplica a x
1 es x a la 24 menos 1 y si dividimos
entre x 1s será igual a x a la 24 menos
1 entre x menos 1 muy bien entonces ya
aquí tenemos una expresión
tenemos una expresión para este
polinomio azul que estamos elevando al
cuadrado entonces fíjate que en realidad
como estamos elevando al cuadrado las
raíces de este polinomio azul se repiten
dos veces se repiten dos veces porque
estamos elevando al cuadrado entonces
vamos a leer nuevamente que decía el
problema para no perdernos y dice
queremos considerar z1 sentados hasta zr
los distintos los distintos ceros
aquí estamos marcando distintos ceros de
px muy bien son aquellos puntos
o aquellos números donde p se anula pero
los queremos distintos y aquí se están
repitiendo dos veces verdad en cursos
más avanzados se le llama que tiene
multiplicidad dos cada uno no nos
importa la multiplicidad simplemente
queremos todos aquellos que son
distintos así que como realmente cero es
una raíz porque aquí tenemos un factor x
ese no nos va a importar mucho
de hecho no nos importa porque 0 no
contribuye en nada a la suma que tenemos
aquí verdad queremos calcular la suma de
los valores absolutos de la parte
imaginaria del cuadrado de las raíces
del polinomio yo sé que es complicado
pero bueno vamos a seguir trabajando en
esto entonces consideremos ya que hemos
observado esto consideremos sólo el
polinomio q de x igual a x a la 23 más x
a la 22
todos estos términos x a la x al
cuadrado más x + 1 sólo nos interesa
saber los perdón las raíces de este
polinomio verdad y justo porque dijimos
que es las de las de pese repiten dos
veces y la de y bueno y además tiene un
cero que no nos importa así que para
simplificar esto qué tal si
multiplicamos además esto de aquí por x
menos uno porque que es lo que nos queda
esto simplemente nos quedaría nos
quedaría x a la 24 menos uno que es este
polinomio amarillo entre x menos 1
todo esto verde es lo mismo que este
polinomio amarillo que fue lo que
obtuvimos aquí en este en este
procedimiento y que de hecho este
procedimiento lo pueden revisar en los
vídeos de series geométricas y además
estamos multiplicando por x menos 1
entonces esto será igual a x a la 24
21 ahora por supuesto uno es raíz de
este polinomio pero en realidad sólo hay
que quitar el 1 porque porque aquí
multiplicamos por x 1 pero eso no estaba
incluido en nuestro polinomio pd x así
que como la raíz de x menos uno es uno
simplemente hay que quitar la raíz uno
de aquí muy bien entonces vamos a
considerar las raíces de este polinomio
que es terriblemente más sencillo que el
que empezamos con esa serie muy rara con
esta perdón esa suma muy rara ahora sólo
tenemos que calcular las raíces de este
polinomio y entonces para calcularlo
simplemente igualamos a cero y quitamos
las raíces que sean iguales a 1 entonces
esto nos dice que x a la 24
debe ser 1 sumando uno de ambos lados y
esto y esto es muy sencillo porque
porque lo que podemos hacer es utilizar
lo que conocemos de de variable compleja
por ejemplo para para poder determinar
quiénes son las raíces de éste
de este de esta las raíces las 23 raíces
distintas de 1 ok entonces tenemos uno
es igual a y al elevado a la cero y cero
podemos pensar como elevado a la cero
pero realmente esto es lo mismo que si
sumamos múltiplos de dos pie entonces
esto es igualado perdón ea lados pi
y esto es igual a la 4
y esto también será igual que si sumamos
otros dos pi
a la 6
y si sumamos otra vez dos pies será
perdón es aquí es que a la 8
y entonces yo creo que ya ya entendiste
cuál es el punto pero si nosotros
queremos calcular la equis simplemente
hay que sacar raíz 24ava por lo que es
lo mismo dividir entre 24 el exponente
en todos estos que tenemos aquí muy bien
y eso nos va a dar las distintas raíces
de uno ok por supuesto estamos pensando
en raíces complejas por ejemplo qué tal
si consideramos bueno esta de aquí
es al acero que es 1 pero si tomamos
esta de aquí tendremos
voy a hacerlo un poquito más abajo
tendremos el lápiz y y simplificamos 2
entre 24 es doceavos verdad es uno entre
12 entonces hay que acordarnos de la
fórmula la fórmula de hoy leer que nos
dice que esto es lo mismo que coseno de
pi entre 12 más y veces el seno de pi
entre 12 muy bien y ahora vamos a
graficar los para ver de qué no se está
hablando esta expresión en esta
expresión vamos a graficar lo
ahí tienen ustedes su plano complejo
este es el eje de la parte real este es
el eje imaginario y digamos que por aquí
está el 1 entonces nuestra primera raíz
es coseno de pido seamos más y seno de
pi doceavos entonces esto es lo mismo
que si nos fijamos digamos en el círculo
unitario y sobre el círculo unitario
aquel punto del plano complejo
con un ángulo de pie entre 12 pero pie
entre 12 que estos son radiales los
puedes pensar como 15 grados verdad 15
grados ahora quién sería el siguiente el
siguiente sería a la 4 y entre 24 que
esto es lo mismo que a al lápiz y entre
6 y al lápiz sextos y pero pi sextos son
30 grados
aquí tendríamos el siguiente
digamos algo así el que le sigue sería a
las 6 p / 24 pues simplificamos
dividimos arriba y abajo entre 6 y nos
queda el lápiz sobre 4 que son pi
cuartos entonces aquí ya tenemos
y cuartos muy bien y así es como podemos
obtener las 23 raíces distintas de uno
de la unidad de uno muy bien entonces
simplemente si te das cuenta lo que
estamos haciendo en cada ocasión es
agregar 15 grados quizás debería ser
para debería pintar lo mejor en otro
plano para para no encimarse todo ahí
todos esos los podemos encontrar en el
círculo unitario sí aquí está por
ejemplo nuestro oops parece más un óvalo
que más o menos ahí está nuestro círculo
unitario
ok ahí va
más o menos ahí está el círculo unitario
entonces tenemos que encontrar 23 raíces
bueno hasta el 1 por supuesto pero
además tenemos que encontrar 23 raíces
entonces aquí está la primera que es y
entre 12 aquí está bien 3
pípi tercios y cuartos aquí seguiría
112 si aquí va cuartos aquí seguiría pit
tercios
y tercios aquí se encuentra alguna la
otra hasta que llegamos a pi medios muy
bien entonces estamos por empezar a
utilizar un concepto distinto para
resolver el problema y me estoy pasando
del tiempo así que mejor seguiremos en
el próximo vídeo